[Musik]
schon früh sucht er die ganz große bühne
lange zeit ist es die showbühne 2006
gewinnt wolodimir selensky das
ukrainische let's dance eine show die er
auch selbst produziert
sein endgültiger durchbruch dass die
serie diener des volkes see lenski wird
zum star nicht nur in der ukraine
sondern auch in russland
er spielt ein geschichtslehrer der zum
präsidenten gewählt wird es wird die
rolle seines lebens
das ungläubige staunen über den punkt in
der dienstvilla selensky nimmt man das
ab
[Musik]
diese marmortreppe aus italien übrigens
eine antiquität marie antoinette hat sie
schon bestehen so hin zur hinrichtung
luxus korruption der einfluss der
allgegenwärtigen oligarchen die serie
trifft einen nerv
und die fiktion wird zur realität see
lenski tritt mit der partei die so heißt
wie seine serie zur präsidentschaftswahl
2009 10 an
die liste seiner partei bestand komplett
aus leuten die noch nie in der regierung
waren junge leute aus ganz verschiedenen
regionen die ukraine hatten die schnauze
voll von all den festgefahrenen reformen
der blockierten wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung sie wollten das system
einfach neu starten
zielinski stammt aus einer jüdischen
familie aus der süd ukraine zu hause
wurde russisch gesprochen er ist jurist
hat aber schon früh auf comedy gesetzt
und macht dort wahlkampf lieber live
shows in einem sender der einem
oligarchen gehört
die witze immer haarscharf vorbei am
guten geschmack
sein motto hauptsache anders
dass das ist ein neues gesicht
es ist dann wahlkampfmodus kaum
interviews wenig konkretes eine öffnung
nach westen und das ende des krieges im
osten wenig unterscheidet ihn da vom
konkurrenten poroschenko mit dem er sich
im olympiastadion von kiew ein wahlkampf
duelle liefert
niederknien vor der fahne inklusive
die wahl nach bringt die sensation so
hoch wie niemand vor ihm gewinnt
selensky es ist diese nacht in der er
zum politiker wird alles ist möglich
ruft er seinen landsleuten aber auch den
nachbarländern zu
hieß es er sagte zu allen menschen in
der postsowjetischen region wenn ich
erfolgreich war könnt ihr es auch sein
er sagte nicht genau welches land er
damit meinte aber die tatsache dass er
das gesagt hat meiner ansicht nach hat
er putin damit herausgefordert in dieser
ersten nacht in
den krieg hat sie lenski geerbt er wird
zum beherrschenden thema seiner
präsidentschaft damals schon 13.000 tote
in dombach see lenski versucht
entschlossen russland zum einlenken zu
bringen
kriegsgefangene werden ausgetauscht der
präsident begrüßt sie persönlich am
flughafen
[Musik]
aber einen draht zu putin findet er
nicht einmal im dezember 2009 10 in
paris treffen die beiden aufeinander
konkrete ergebnisse gibt es nicht
innenpolitisch versucht seelands die
sicherheits korruptionsbekämpfer sein
name allerdings findet sich auch in den
pandora papers offshore-konten passe
nicht zum image eines saubermanns seine
zustimmungswerte sinken
als russische truppen an den grenzen der
ukraine stehen fordert sie lenski
unterstützung des westens und macht das
was er am besten kann kommunikation per
social media auch dann noch als putin
die ukraine wirklich angreift
ich bin hier wir werden unsere waffen
nicht niederlegen wir werden unser land
verteidigen weil unsere waffe die
wahrheit ist und die wahrheit ist das
ist unser land unser staat unsere kinder
und wir werden all das verteidigen
er
weiß wie er in die kamera zu schauen und
zu sprechen hat er trifft den richtigen
ton trifft die richtige länge seiner
botschaften er kann emotionalität
vermitteln und das ist insbesondere für
seine landsleute glaube ich eine ganz
ganz wichtige
form der mitteilung der botschaft
da ist jemand der kümmert sich um uns
steht uns beide setzt sich für uns alle
die lenski als superman mit seinen
kindern und seiner frau die im land
geblieben sind sie hat die bilder auf
ihrem instagram account geteilt der
plattform bei der es vor allem ums image
geht im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
wird der krieg auch auf social media
geführt
zielinski ist überall spricht vor dem
eu-parlament vor hunderttausenden
demonstranten in ganz europa überall
fliegen ihm die herzen zu und respekt
wir wissen nicht ob sie denn es geht
diesen krieg überlebt das wird
sicherlich auch eine wirkung haben auf
die rezeption dieser beiträge die jetzt
erstellt werden und es wird eine
erzählung von ihm geführt die eine ganz
historische phase der ukraine beschreibt
und diverse lenski bestimmen wo
kriegsherr staatsmann nicht von ungefähr
erinnert das was er vor dem britischen
unterhaus sagt dann die berühmte rede
von winston churchill 1940 damals als
hitler deutschland noch unschlagbar
schien
[Applaus]
wir werden nicht aufgeben und wir werden
nicht verlieren wir werden bis zum ende
kämpfen auf see in der luft wir werden
weiterkämpfen für unser land egal wie
hoch der preis sein wird
zielinski ist jetzt ein kriegspräsident
verleiht worden tröstet verwundete es
ist eine rolle von der er gehofft hatte
sie nie spielen zu müssen
[Musik]